sentido
[Música]
de ese mes de miles de emigrantes
irregulares etíopes llevan meses en
centros de detención en arabia saudita
en la última semana sus peticiones de
ayuda se han multiplicado en las redes
sociales
los detenidos denuncian el hacinamiento
insalubridad y falta de alimentos
condiciones de detención inadmisible es
que nuestra observadora documento con
imágenes grabadas en secreto
son muchos y las autoridades sauditas no
les proporcionan suficiente comida ni
agua
reciben un pan por la mañana y otro por
la noche solo dos panes al día en cuanto
al agua cada día
es decir cada 24 horas
eso es todo
me contaron que debido al hacinamiento
menudo tienen que dormir en los baños
para distanciarse un poco de los demás
y a veces se enferman por esto
cuando llaman a los guardias y les dicen
que un compañero está enfermo según sus
testimonios
los guardias sacan a la persona la
golpea y luego la traen de vuelta
el pasado mes de agosto 10 etíopes
murieron en un centro de detención en
yeda para etiopía esta situación es una
forma de represalia por la construcción
de una gran represa en el río nilo un
proyecto al que se oponen los países de
la liga árabe incluida arabia saudita
los dos países acordaron la repatriación
de los etíopes 40.000 ya regresaron pero
al menos 80.000 más siguen detenidos
a menudo sus familiares que están en
etiopía me dicen tengo un hijo una hija
en arabia saudita
y no sé en qué prisión está
hay que saber que muchas veces la
persona no puede decirle a sus
familiares dónde está encarcelada si los
teléfonos están prohibidos en los
centros de detención
todos los presos etíopes viven en estas
condiciones catastróficas
y lo único que quieren es salir de la
cárcel y volver a su país lo antes
posible
[Música]
entre 17 y alquimistas animadamente
sueños y manitas
la inesperada erupción del volcán irá
gong o el 22 de mayo en el este de la
república democrática del congo destruyó
muchos barrios de la ciudad de goma y
también dejó al menos 32 muertos cuatro
meses después miles de damnificados aún
no han vuelto a la vida normal y viven
en refugios improvisados
nuestro observador nos comenta sobre la
situación en el campamento principal que
está situado en una escuela local fui al
centro para damnificados de calle donde
me recibió el jefe del campamento quien
me mostró el registro de seis mil
hogares inscritos
después entramos en el campamento donde
la situación es catastrófica algunas
familias pasan la noche a la intemperie
otras duermen en las aulas incluso hay
familias que duermen en un cobertizo no
hay baños y se teme que haya una
epidemia de cólera en el campamento solo
viven del trueque si das tu ropa te dan
comida
a corto plazo la población quiere ayuda
humanitaria tener alimentos agua refugio
temporal a largo plazo la población pide
al gobierno que les devuelva sus
parcelas en sus respectivos barrios para
poder reconstruir y retomar una vida
normal en respuesta a la situación
humanitaria el gobierno de la provincia
de kivú del norte construyó unos 1000
refugios temporales en el norte de la
ciudad de goma sin embargo a mediados
del mes de septiembre las autoridades
aún no habían anunciado las fechas de
traslado de los damnificados a este
nuevo lugar
estos samuráis japoneses que recolectan
basura son de hecho un grupo de actores
callejeros preocupados por el medio
ambiente que decidieron recorrer las
calles de tokio recogiendo basuras desde
los pequeños callejones hasta las
avenidas concurridas ellos no escatiman
esfuerzos y tienen un mensaje positivo
que transmitir
es cierto que hay un problema de basura
en todo el mundo la gente la tira
pero cuando tokio fue elegida ciudad
para los juegos olímpicos
pensé que gente de todo el mundo vendría
a japón para esta ocasión
y que sería mejor recibirlos en un país
limpio
por eso me interesé en la recolección de
residuos
me convertí en un samurai recolector de
basuras
hay un tipo de desechos que ha aumentado
desde el inicio de la pandemia de kobe
las mascarillas cada vez se ven más
mascarillas en nuestras calles
[Música]
la gente cree que solo limpiamos los
residuos
pero en realidad estamos limpiando los
corazones impuros de las personas que
arrojaron la basura
culpar al pecado no al pecador es la
idea que inspira nuestra recogida de
residuos
eso es todo por esta semana en los
observadores de france 24 si desean
contactar a nuestro equipo editorial o
equipo de producción nuestros contactos
aparecen en sus pantallas envíenos sus
historias imágenes o vídeos nosotros nos
vemos la próxima semana aquí en los
observadores hasta pronto